Speaker 1: Herschel Walker has a brilliant new
idea. By the way, in the midst of this hectic
campaign and race to the finish line tomorrow,
Herschel Walker says, hey, you know what?
We've got all of these IRS or as he calls them,
our ACE agents who are going to be carrying guns.
Let's get them to stop. The men in women's sports.
This is an incredible idea coming from a guy who
has very few ideas. Let's take a listen to it.
Speaker 2: And instead of trying to keep
them safe, they are going to put me in a
women's sport. And I'm like, wait a minute,
this is how you solve this problem. Get rid of
them. 87,000 IRS agents are going to go over all
of us and put one of those areas agent in his
school to take care of the kids. That's what
they need to be doing instead of going after us in
these areas. But yet they don't know how to spend
their money. Now they want to spend your money.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Did did you catch that? I mean,
did you did you understand the idea?
Speaker 2: And instead of trying to
keep them safe, they were going to put me in
a women's sport. And I'm like, wait a minute,
this is how you solve this problem. Get rid of
them. 87,000 IRS agents are going to go out,
all of us, and put one of those IRAs agent in
schools to take care of our kids. That's what
they need to be doing instead of going after
those in these areas age. But yet they don't
know how to spend their money.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, I think that this is obviously crazy, but
it's important to know the truth about the IRS
agent story. The right is framing the hiring of
IRS agents as some kind of dystopian crackdown
on the people or whatever the case may be. A
couple different things that are important to
understand. Number one, over the next decade,
55,000 IRS agents are going to be retiring. So
55,000 of the hiring of the to be hired agents are
over the next decade and they're just to replace
55,000 that are retiring. That's number one.
Number two, the IRS is understaffed. If you
actually want to hold the wealthy accountable
and make sure that they're actually paying the
taxes that they should be paying and the things we
always say and that many Republicans say is, well,
you need them. You need staff to do that. You need
employees to be able to do that. And so increasing
increasing staffing beyond just replacing
those retiring makes sense. And then lastly,
the entire gun thing. Okay. It's really a red
herring. First of all, across the entire country,
there's 2100 IRS agents from the criminal
investigation side. These are essentially
police who carry firearms. Herschel Walker and
others want you to believe that they're going to
be arming random IRS auditors, auditing people
making $60,000 a year because they claim too
many deductions. Okay. That's not what this is.
That's not what this is. And by the way, many
agencies have divisions that are law enforcement
and carry guns. If you look at the MTA, right,
the Metropolitan Transit Authority in New York
City, or if you look up in Boston at the MBT,
they all have like some version of their transit
police. They carry guns. It's not the subway
operator is now armed. Okay. It's really not a
big deal. Amtrak, Amtrak has police. Yes. They
carry guns. It's not a huge thing. Now, the good
news as far as Georgia goes is that Republicans
are losing a little bit of hope. Now we have
just hours until we know the results. Everybody
should vote. I don't mention this in order to
get people to take any action or not take any
action. If you can vote in Georgia, you should
vote in Georgia. That's it. But Republicans,
according to a new Politico article which we
will link to, are feeling increasingly grim. Is
the word that's used here about Herschel Walker's
chances. Let's indeed hope that that is the case.